today i'm going to be speaking with dan
kavalak who is a labor and human rights
attorney and also
author of the book canceled this book
the progressive case
against cancel culture uh it's great to
have you on dan
it's great to be here david thank you so
the reason i'm interested in this
is um there are certainly a range of
views
across the political spectrum about this
issue of so-called cancer culture and
what what counts as cancer culture and
what doesn't
but even within the left there is some
disagreement as to whether it's taking
place
what counts what should be done maybe
start
by kind of giving us your sense of
relative to the idea that we hear
on right-wing media about this as a sort
of
uh speech suppression politically based
epidemic that is taking place in media
and academia and across the social and
cultural
areas how does your position compare to
that as a starting point
yes compared to the right wing position
i think
mine is certainly uh different
first of all i'm not hysterical about it
i mean i
i i try to deal with it in a reason way
i
i certainly am concerned about it um
you know they i'll just give examples
like i'm not concerned
about the fact that pepe le pew's not
going to be in the next uh
this uh movie yeah um that was decided
by the producers
and you know i certainly think
that he is a problematic character who
basically his only thing he ever did was
assault the
uh other uh skunk um the same thing with
the
um dr seuss uh issue i mean
the um estate itself apparently
if dr seuss decided to get rid of these
six books which no one ever heard of
and which you know were offensive and i
think dr seuss
um progressed in his thoughts as he
got older right and and that
actually is a good segue into what i am
concerned about what would concern me
is if all of dr seuss's books
were canceled because of his earlier
works
okay the concern i have about
cancer culture particularly on the left
um
is that it seems to me there's a lack of
forgiveness
and chance for redemption for people
you make one mistake and i've seen this
all of us have seen this many times and
that's why
people who deny the cancer culture exist
i i just think are not
being honest we see many times someone
will do something
that is offensive or barely offensive or
seen by someone as offensive and they're
immediately shut out people call for
them to be fired
sometimes they'll get fired that
concerns me
so let's break down that process so that
we can maybe even figure out which is
the part that concerns you because
so let's imagine a situation where
someone tweets something
that we agree is offensive not related
to their work
while they are on the weekend or you
know there was the story that john
ronson talks about in his book so you've
been publicly shamed a woman who tweeted
um something about white versus black
people getting aids as she stepped onto
a flight and then when she landed it
exploded into an international story
and photographers were waiting for her
and whatever okay so
the thing is said then there is a public
outcry from people who say this is bad
sometimes you'll see the public contact
the employer of the individual
and ask for them to be fired even if
what was said
doesn't does arguably not directly
relate to the person's job
the employer will then sometimes put out
a statement
sometimes they'll say we are
disciplining the person sometimes they
will
fire the person now at every individual
level
people tweeting outrage seems to be
something that
i don't have a problem with people
tweeting outrage people demanding that
the person be fired
is a question mark for me and this this
has been done to me
before in fact as well in the sense that
certainly calling a business if you find
out the person works somewhere and
you're going to say
if this person works for you i'm not
going to be a patron of your business
certainly something i can't say is wrong
to do although i might disagree with it
and then the firing decision an employer
can decide as long as they're not
discriminating on the basis of protected
class
it's no longer good for our business to
have this person working for us so like
the pieces all when you break them down
the way i'm doing it
aren't particularly concerning so like
which aspect
is it you are most worried about well
first of all
i mean the context is everything and
i mean it's one thing if you just if you
find out someone is an avowed white
supremacist
okay at night dresses up but you know in
a hood and
in his part of the ku klux klan this is
a person
with bad motives bad intentions
i think how you deal with that person
would be different
than someone who who is otherwise
well-intentioned who says something
inadvertently sure offensive or does
something inadvertently
uh offensive i think they need to be
treated differently i
i don't think you should pile on someone
even on social media who makes a mistake
and who says look i'm sorry right and
that happens a lot right
and usually even after the i'm sorry it
doesn't end
right and i certainly don't think you
should try to get someone like that
fired except in the most egregious
circumstance
i don't see getting someone fired in
most circumstances
some act of social activism i see it
as something counter to solidarity
with your fellow workers with your
fellow comrades many times
and this concerns me greatly especially
in the academy now and i talk about this
in my book i think a lot of people don't
understand
that the academy has gone through a huge
transformation
in recent decades from tenured
professors
on the most part to now adjunct
professors most
professors now are adjunct what does
that mean means they don't have tenure
they have no job security they get paid
poverty wages uh i'm an adjunct
for example i get three thousand dollars
per class i teach at the law school i
may teach 50 students
to pay 40 grand a year to attend it
right
and i get three grand for the whole
class and can be fired mid
semester i have not you know i'm you
know
basically a glorified uh you know
gig worker right right yeah and i've
taught adjunct as well
at boston college and i've had a similar
experience and to call
lightly and i think many times it's
likely for someone like that to be fired
is kicking down it's not punching up
it's not
fighting you're not taking on the man in
fact i agree with you
is uniting with the man right the
administrators who make a lot of money
hundreds of thousands of dollars if not
over a million
against these lowly adjuncts and you see
this
a lot um yeah a woman named amy siskind
a democratic activist
tried to get me fired for from boston
college because
i i responded to a tweet of hers saying
that the 2020
nominee or maybe it was even 2016
2020 shouldn't be white or a man and i
said that seems to me
to be wrong to to disqualify someone on
the basis of sex or race and she tried
to get me fired
from boston college and that's wrong but
what i'm hearing from you
is more that you just think sometimes
these tools are wielded when they
shouldn't be like there's more egregious
and less egregious cases and sometimes
you just think
the action doesn't rise to warranting a
call to be fired for example
i think it would be a rare case where
that would be legitimate
let me put it that way but i do think
you know there's something
that people now refer to the overton
window yeah
you've probably heard that that there is
a line
there are lines of demarcation again i
think if someone
is in a vowel racist and a vowed white
supremacist
um you know uh particularly in a
sensitive position
of power um i think it's legitimate
to call that person out publicly
and and with their employer but who gets
to who gets to decide what rises to what
level and if the position is sensitive
well that's a great question i mean i
think uh
obviously it's up to the individual
who's doing the attempted canceling if
we want to say that
okay has to use some judgment um
but i think giving what i'm illustrating
is
that you would do this very rarely you
know
there's you know not that many uh
there are obviously uh uh avowed white
supremacists but
you know most of the people we come in
contact with on a daily basis are not
that
and and most of the people that are
being canceled are not that in fact
you know the irony is uh to calling
someone a racist or a sexist
is only damaging to people who don't
want to be racist or sexist right i mean
if you're in a vowed racist that's a
compliment i got a guess
so what would be what would be an
example of someone who
said was called a racist and then fired
but what they said was just a
lapse in judgment and really they
shouldn't have been
okay well i'll give an example um
from my book and why i wrote the book
because of something that happened in
pittsburgh
and this was uh not someone who was
fired but in a way it was it was even
greater than being
fired so um in pittsburgh we have this
peace and justice group called the
thomas merton center
and it was founded 50 years ago
co-founded by someone named molly rush
a long time peace activist and also
someone who's advocated
for economic and racial justice
during the uh george floyd protest of
last summer
she uh posted on facebook reposted
like someone had posted it and she just
hit share which many of us do
you know without thinking she posted
this meme
with a picture of martin luther king and
it said
never rioted never looted change the
world
immediately people started jumping on
her
on facebook attacking her as a racist
attacking her family who defended her
calling them white trash uh she
apologized on facebook publicly
but that wasn't enough what what ended
up happening
happening is the thomas merton center
the board of the thomas merton center
put out a letter
both to all uh thomas merton center
members
and uh publicly on facebook
saying they could no longer work with
molly rush yeah
after 50 years and this is
uh you know so the argument was this
meme was racist because
you shouldn't tell african americans how
to fight for their liberation
right if there's some violence that
ensues
it's not for us to say and of course
though as i point out in my book
if you look at a lot of the violence
that happened
a lot of it probably the vast majority
was not
done by african americans it was done
either by young white anarchists
usually young white males or young white
male right wingers trying to
either inflame the situation or to
delegitimize
black lives matter so uh
calling those people out
uh why is that problematic in fact in
portland as i mentioned there were
newspaper articles that quoted people
from
black lives matter and from the naacp
saying that the violence that took place
night after night in portland at around
midnight and later
um had nothing to do with black lives
matter yeah
yeah something else this was again young
white people who were anarchist or
whatever they were
who decided they wanted to do what they
wanted to do which was
attack the federal courthouse night
after night i think this is a great
example i mean listen if this example is
as you describe it and i have no reason
to doubt it i'm just saying i'm
what i know about it is what you're
telling me this would be one where i i
agree
this this sounds like the wrong solution
but in a i guess
where i worry is that in a country of
331 million people
there's examples of everything every
good company that's a big company is
gonna have a hundred
or a thousand customer experiences that
sound terrible but they represent
very little in the scope of the how the
company deals with customers as an
example
you know uh i i worry that the
this is being called an epidemic when i
will
grant that in a country of 331 million
the example just you gave me sounds
terrible it sounds completely
counterproductive
to the goals of me as a person on the
left for example i'm with you if the
details are as described
i just don't see the epidemic and
individually it sounds like
you certainly defend the people the
right of people to express their
distaste on social media right like you
and i are on the same page there
yes absolutely and you certainly defend
the right
of individuals to tell a company i won't
do business with you
because of this whether they're right or
wrong you defend the right that they
have to do that
well certainly consumers have that right
they certainly have that legal right
they should
yeah again as a matter of discretion
sure
whether or a matter of conscience
whether they should do it
that that's another question but i see
people have the legal right to do that
and then businesses as as businesses
that exist
some are regulated in certain ways and
some some are others as long as they're
not breaking any laws
they can also decide having a certain
employee is bad for us and it could hurt
profits or whatever
we don't want this employee working for
us that you agree with
yes of course so it sounds like really
it's the
sometimes overbearing activation of
these tactics that you're concerned
about well yes and again i
i never use the word epidemic in my book
or when i talk about this
yeah and i wouldn't use that uh but i do
think
it is uh i i think it is a
frequently used tactic uh
against people particularly in the
academy the academy's really
um soaked in this stuff
uh you know again just to give a couple
examples off the bat there was this
woman
last summer again during the height of
the george floyd protest
a professor who apparently or some
people thought fell asleep during a zoom
call
in which racial diversity was being
talked about people said she should be
fired
um you had this couple at yale
who simply they were residential
professors
meaning they lived on campus and were in
charge of residential life
uh during halloween they refused to give
any guidance or rules as to what kind of
costumes
people could wear and people thought
well that's
insensitive you should tell people not
to wear certain costumes races or
whatever
costumes uh when in fact the professors
were just like we trust that you're
gonna make the right decision and people
were you know
clamored for them to be kicked off
campus because
uh their decision-making was being
respected
i mean these are now did that work were
they kicked off campus
i don't know the answer to that because
i think that another aspect to this dan
is there's no doubt that the general
population
is is of course going i mean listen look
at what's going on with covet guidelines
what's the reason that the cdc and
others have to be so careful in what
they say
that tons of people will misunderstand
deliberately or not and they'll do the
wrong thing
i think that one of the things that's
important is
in many of the cases where there is a
clamoring where maybe you and i wouldn't
agree that someone should be fired or
canceled
the systems are robust enough that the
cancellation doesn't happen and that's
why i asked about these folks being
kicked off campus
because if they weren't then sure we can
say hey you know what the clamoring for
them to be kicked off campus was wrong
but they weren't kicked off meaning that
the system the system worked
yeah well i i although i think there's a
lot of cases where that's not true
okay people were kicked off yeah um or
their classes at least suspended
um there was a case a guy he all of his
classes were suspended because
i believe it was a japanese word that he
was using
nige which means kind of well
or it's a transitional phrase and people
thought it sounded too much like the
n-word
complained okay he lost his classes okay
this is again there's a lot of cases
yeah again again if that's true that's
nuts but i think it's important like
when we say a lot
right we're usually talking about you
know
a few anecdotes like if someone came to
me and said
in a country of 331 million 5
000 teachers were fired because they did
a you know
like i think it's important to keep that
context right right and again
i don't want to jump on the bandwagon
that this is a national crisis okay
because i don't think it is
but the message of tread carefully is a
good one yes
and and by the way as i mentioned in the
la in in one chapter
near the end of the book there are a lot
of you know who's really being
persecuted or people who advocate on
behalf of palestinians they are often
uh deplatformed fired
not hired because people say they're
anti-semitic
because they advocate for palestinian
rights even
bishop desmond tutu of south africa who
won a nobel prize
uh was uninvited uh uh to speak
because they said his position that uh
israel was also an apartheid state was
somehow racist so
uh and there's been scores of cases uh
like that so but you're right but i will
give if i can give one example because i
know
that our time's running out where this
is becoming more systematic
um the trump administration actually
seized on this
uh at the national labor relations board
his
norb was the most right-wing anti-union
board
we've ever had right and i can say that
because i was a labor lawyer
for 26 years so i know of what i speak
and they issued a decision in the case
of general motors
at the end of 2019 which
overturned years of board law
and made it easier to fire employees
engaged in union activity
for us offensive speech it used to be
much harder to do that the idea was
if i'm involved in a strike or in
collective bargaining
i may say you know you talking to you is
the manager you bastard you know you're
screwing us
um and the board was very uh
reluctant to fire someone like that it
was seen as protected
you'd be relatively insulated from
repercussions for that
right even if there was a racial or or
sexist
uh tinge to to what you were saying as
long as you weren't threatening violence
okay
the trump board overturned all that law
and basically said look if the if the
employer finds your speech offensive
and not we're not going to look to
whether it's objectively offensive
as we used to they can fire you and in
this case in the general motors case
it was an african-american employee who
was fired
in part because during negotiations he
pretended to be a slave saying oh yes
massa this sort of thing
uh in in arguing with the employer
and the board upheld his discipline
okay so this
and it's not because the trump
administration was
a was woke in terms of racial justice
right or because economic they seized on
this
mood to
crack down on workers rights
and i think that we have to see that
that is a huge
potential when you have
people being you know willy-nilly called
to be fired
uh for these sorts of things because
most people in this
economy have no rights yes they don't
have unions to protect them
they don't have a just cause provision
they don't have tenure
they can be fired like that and ruby
and i think there has to be on the part
of
leftists and liberals who consider
themselves activists and people of
conscience
they need to be very reluctant to take
away people's jobs
i i think that uh there's no question
about that and there's sort of different
categories here as well i mean you know
the
the calls for firings seem to me to be a
very different thing
than like the washington redskins
deciding that hey
redskins and this picture of a red guy
are completely
out of touch with the way people relate
to each other right now
and that should go and and i think where
the right sometimes goes off the deep
end on this is they bunch it all
together and they do a sort of gish
gallop and they say look at all
this stuff whereas what makes sense to
do
which is what i think you're trying to
do is to look specifically at instances
where
the tech the tactic is not calibrated to
the substance
yes yes i think we have to have a
reasonable discussion about that
and i think we have to let people air
make mistakes again
if they're well intentioned educate them
but not the first move should not be to
punish
i i don't think that that is the type of
movement
we should be seeking yeah i saw i don't
know if you saw this but there i i don't
follow the
story super closely but i think it was a
miami heat player
who a couple weeks ago during some
online game
used the k word about jews and things
exploded
and julian edelman the nfl football
player who's half jewish or
considers himself jewish now um
reached out and said you know i'm not
going to assume
you said what you said because you know
exactly what it means in its history and
whatever
let's get together and talk about it and
a lot of people
liked that but at the same time as an
organization the miami heat decided we
have to do something about it so it's
clear that we we aren't standing by it
and i think also the responses that are
the right ones may be different
depending on who's responding as
evidenced in this case
yes and i agree um in in in
your example is interesting because it
just shows how things have changed with
technology i mean
now every virtually everything we say
is captured somewhere right on an iphone
on a computer in a video game as you say
um and again i i certainly think people
shouldn't be throwing around racial
epithets
um at the same time again to jump on
people for things that they say in the
heat of the moment
on a video game or something again i i'm
just reluctant
uh to do that yeah i think heat of the
moment you know with all the there's a
double edge to all of these i mean heat
of the moment
remember the mel gibson thing where the
you know with
with the the the a cop that happened to
be jewish and the whole thing about are
you a jew or whatever and then said
well i was drunk no matter how drunk i
am dan
i'm not going to accidentally say
anti-semitic things so the idea of heat
of the moment and inebria it's like it
came from
so i think that all of these things have
to be balanced i think is the message
well i think that's right i think that's
right and i again i think
at least to approach these things with
your first
you know your first goal being
understanding and
forgiveness and a chance for redemption
i think is the way to go that that
that's my main message that seems
completely plausible to me um the the
book is fascinating
it's called cancel this book the
progressive case against cancel culture
we've been speaking with the book's
author daniel kavalak
and i really appreciate your time today
dan david it was wonderful i'd love to
come back